[موسيقى]
قد تبدو رذاذه الملح اكثر الاصناف زهدا
على المائده لكن التاريخ يراها من اثمن ما
وجد ويخبرك ايضا بان حفنه ملح كانت تشتري
بشرا في ازمنه تجاره الرق الاسود قبل ان
يصبح منكها لطعامك فما القصه في العصور
القديمه كان الناس يسدون حاجه اجسادهم الى
الملح من اللحوم التي يصطادونها قبل ان
يجدوا ان مياه البحار المالحه تعطي النكهه
ذاتها فاستخدموا طرقا قديمه لاستخراجه
كنتظار تبخره بمواسم الجفاف وهو ما ثبت
عند الصينيين قبل نحو سته الاف عام قبل
الميلاد
كذلك اعتمد المصريون القدماء على تبخير
مياه النيل لاستخراج الملح وكانوا اول من
استخدمه لحفظ الطعام كما استخدمه لغايه
اخرى كالطقوس الدينيه وربطوه بضراء الخاصه
ما بين نحو 400 الى 800 عام قبل الميلاد
عرفت حضاره
تعدين الملح فوجدت مناجم للملح في النمسا
وكان بمثابه مصدر للدخل والثروه في الوقت
نفسه كان الفرنسيون يستخرجونه من الجنابيع
المالحه عن طريق ملء احواض خزفيه بالمياه
المالحه وتبخيرها لتكوين كعكه كبيره من
الملح جيلا بعد جيل ازدادت اهميه الملح
واستخداماته فضمنته بعض الشعوب في
قرابينها كما استخدمه الاغريق كعمله
واشتروا به العبيد اما الرومان فجعلوه
جزءا من راتب الجندي وكانوا اول من استخدم
احواض ملح الرصاص لتبخير المحلول الملحي
في اوائل العصور الوسطى ابتكرت تقنيات
الترشيح من خلال ملء حفره كبيره من الصخور
المالحه بالمياه العذبه لتمتص الملح ثم
يتم استخراجه من المحلول الناتج وهي
التقنيه التي استخدمت اول مره بالنمسا في
منتصف القرن السادس عشر ظهرت في اقليم
لومباردي الايطالي تقنيات ممرات التخرج
حيث يجري الماء المالح فوق مسارات محدده
لتكوين محلول ملحي وهي طريقه اثبتت
فعاليتها ايضا خلال القرن السابع عشر بدا
استخدام مضخات المحلول الملحي التي تعمل
اما يدويا واما بعجله الماء او بمحلج
الحصان وقد زاد ذلك من فعاليه عمليه
التكرير
منذ منتصف القرن الثامن عشر فصاعدا اصبح
الملح مطلوبا كسلعه للصناعات الكيماويه ما
عاد بتحسينات على عمليات الاستخراج
والتقنيات كما اصبح عنصرا مهما على طاوله
الطعام في الماذيب الكبرى وقيست رتبه
الضيوف بدرجه قربهم من موقع الملح على
الطاوله حتى القرن التاسع عشر لم يسهل على
الاشخاص العاديين الحصول على الملح فتحول
لسلعه سياسيه ففرضت له ضريبه في دول عده
واستخدم كسلاح ضد المتمردين وكان سببا من
اسباب الثوره الفرنسيه مع حلول النصف
الثاني من القرن العشرين وعلى الرغم من ان
التقنيات لا تزال هي نفسها كما كانت في
القرون السابقه اصبح الملح منتجا يوميا
رخيصا لا يخلو بيت منه ولكن كمنكهه طعام
لا اكثر